よし
ああ
皆さんにはこれが何に見えるか人はこれをお風呂というかもしれないいつから人はこれ
お風呂と言うようになったか簡単な話ですみんなが普段入るお風呂という存在がい年は
その他立つという固定概念にとらわれてしまっているからみんなはこれを送ろうという
だか私たちが私はこれを送るという固定概念で見ることなくもっと広い視野で見
たとき
お皿に見えたお風呂のポテ概念を取っ払って考えてみてくださいこれはどう見てもお皿
大きなお皿です愛と勇気で新品のオフ会お皿を買いました綺麗な状況なので僕からもう
黄黒じゃありませんおお皿として見ていましてその前提で行くよ会というわけでもう
すぐ
地蔵か分かることになります最後にはもう静岡でみんなデカいことしようかなと思って
皆だよ
カレーパーティー
してんだと思ったんですよ大きなお皿にカレーをいっぱい持ってみんなで食べようと
思ったんですけども大きなお皿が見当たらない
もっと死んだ僕はもうお皿にしか見えなくなりましたという意味で静岡の給食センター
からご飯カレーライフ
たくさん準備してもらったぞそういうわけで今日はお風呂いいなぁ
お皿この奥義のお皿いっぱいにカレーを守ってみんなで食べていきたいと思いますそれ
済みな感じ
でしてほしいの1回もうもう黒として作っていません新品を買いましたとしてきれい
ですもう食器等が思っていることを勘違いしないで頂きたいから
家のお風呂でやっちゃダメだぞてない子ペアた速カレーを装っていきまも懐かしい
んだぞするがすげー給食っぽいなぁうわぁやああっ
このバンド線できない国家給食当番に高いままです
あーでも多いなぁ
[音楽]
やって混ぜないと思う心得るしてボク
あります
[音楽]
入ってきました
たいというわけで今日の給食の準備ができたので皆を呼びます美祢市まあ
阿部よ給食の時間だよでも美味しそうなんだけど結局てたらまずね夕食食べられるする
んだけど
はいはい今就職の時間だいやあああちゃミニーちゃん前に前です
生きるいいいいいいいいいいいい
今時間
なきゃ30はやばいよあの女牡丹その分5月にクリスと肉って思う
じゃあいただきますかいただきまーすげぇー4
私じゃねぇ
まーすとスアを言えねぇ
余裕でしょこれはあげる9事前に2人にまあ考え食べないように出来てるんでいける
でしょ
[音楽]
結構深いなった
朝夕に見えますけど結構ありますからねぇ
ええええええ
4日
me
けがを負った
大丈夫撃ち抜かれたよなんかホモなんだよ
まああとちょっとあ
大して変わってないふういうわけでちょっと3人だったまつげなく無理だったので
ちょっとずつ人をやっていきます
me
[音楽]
これ一体一体の
作ってます凄い編集するって合法的に女の子とご飯食べれるんだよ
サバイすごいよなってやっぱり頑張ったってぜってー音とこの人は食べなさそうな
女の子とかと食べるんだよ
吉兼すごいたとえここからもう無理なんだよ
統合から女の子と食べれないもなんだった
お疲れお疲れを使え
3勝はい
ん
par
みんな鈴ンってくださいどうぞの立つ
カレーどうぞああああ
ana
コはそれだ歳でスパ
大丈夫
奪ってそこ見えてきたそこ等結構すればからちょっとこれは期待を振って膿んでるって
いう
なんでいけばさすがに入ってねー写し取り3人前長所つつ医師会でずハゼ14人万円
くらいか
taroo
[音楽]
oo
生きよう
どうぞよろしくショックレー
難しいうわああああああいやちょっとなりますよ
添えぞ
[音楽]
もうザってもう4時だよ
やばいなーマジ室ご本尊さっ
さっきマネーオシャレな朝ゴハンといいお昼ごはんの本だとか言ってやってたな
ええっ
あのぐらいスパ
ああああ
あーあついて歌等の配管部材がをする先生のどうするが
シャア
[音楽]
だめだか
も食えねえねえ
のごちそうさまでした
me
[音楽]